an unprecedented food crisis is
engulfing the world
supercharged by the war in ukraine
it's brought rising food prices
malnutrition and the potential for much
much worse it threatens to keep tens of
millions of people over the edge into
mass anger and famine
[Music]
until recently global hunger was in
decline
but since 2014 it's been rising
over the past two years the number of
people without regular access to food
has more than doubled
some 800 million people already go to
bed hungry every night
and now the world's food system has been
hit with a perfect storm
2022 was already looking like a terrible
year for global hunger azkovitz still
continued to grip some parts of the food
supply chain worldwide you had a series
of bad harvest in recent years because
of climate change this all disrupted
food production those two shocks climate
change and the pandemic have meant that
according to one estimate global supply
of wheat one of the world's most
important carbohydrates has fallen for
the first time in four years
and then the what happened
[Music]
ukraine's food exports all but stopped
trapping around 25 million tons of corn
and wheat inside the country
equivalent to the annual consumption of
all of the world's least developed
economies
ukraine's food exports are hugely
important to the global food supply it's
a big powerhouse in terms of grain
production
it's one of the world bed baskets and
with that bread basket off the market
prices rocketed
imagine if you were buying your food
from ukraine
and now let's say you need to go to
canada
or australia
or argentina
that means
that you will have to pay more
because of extra freight
and you will have to pay more in time
because it will take you longer and you
will pass these costs
to the consumer
and other shocks have made the crisis
worse
we are in uncharted territory because
not only do we have a food crisis with
multiple causes
but also this is coming on top of
an energy crisis and also a fertiliser
crisis
farms run on fuel and fertilizer as
prices of both have risen farmers profit
margins have been squeezed
and if they're forced to cut back on
fertilizer because it's too expensive or
unavailable
their yields will fall even more
at the worst possible time
that will impact the production
of major commodities
for the next year
and then
we are looking at availability crisis
imagine what that would do
to food prices
it's a vicious cycle with potentially
catastrophic consequences
and nowhere on earth is immune
in america rising food and energy costs
have helped push inflation to its
highest level since 1981.
food prices in britain are rising at a
rate not seen for 13 years
and in poorer countries things are even
worse
[Music]
the food crisis has already hit home
she's been selling hobstabuna a
traditional tunisian bread made with
semolina for the last 35 years
now the cost of her ingredients are
going up and customers are buying less
leaving her with less money to feed her
family
usually imports about 42 of its wheat
from ukraine
and relies on it for sunflower oil
another crucial commodity with those
imports gone tunisia has struggled to
find other suppliers it can afford
meaning shortages for people like suade
hunger is turning to anger
as food disappears from shelves there's
a risk tunisians could lose patience
with their government
i'm really really concerned about how
this crisis can
stoke civil unrest in 2008 we saw
riots in upwards of 40 countries
in 2011
we saw riots but also the start of the
arab spring
[Applause]
today we are looking at something which
we haven't seen before
while the tunisian revolution in 2011
wasn't caused by higher food prices some
believe it was a contributing factor
[Applause]
and it's not just in tunisia where
hunger looks set to cause problems for
governments
the economists modeling suggests that
many countries could see a doubling of
the number of serious outbreaks of
unrest over the next year
and it wouldn't just be anger driving
this unrest but a genuine fear of going
hungry
households in sub-saharan africa already
spend up to 40 percent of their income
feeding themselves
a rise in prices means millions won't be
able to afford to eat
in many many cases
their best day
is like
our worst day
imagine if you are spending 50 percent
of your income
just on food
how much space do you have for anything
else and then
the prices of two things which really
really matter meaning your food and your
fuel
they go up
governments are tapped out
there are no safety nets
those that do have supplies have been
turning inwards
there are a number of fixes that
countries are turning to one of the
unfortunate ones is protectionism
that is to say export controls and
stockpiling
following severe heat waves earlier this
year india banned wheat exports
in total 23 countries now have severe
restrictions on food exports
the thing is they might be doing
themselves more harm than good
time and again it has been proven that
it doesn't help inside the country which
puts the export ban it doesn't help
outside the country
export bans can make a price problem
worse
farmers may hoard their products until
the ban is lifted
or they might even switch to another
crop
that would reduce domestic supply
further and push prices up
whilst you can sympathize with these
countries that are doing this
the result is potentially much higher
prices for everyone else
that means the challenge faced by some
of the world's poorest countries could
grow even further
we need to help governments
reach their populations
with affordable food with affordable
fuel with fertilizer and what that will
require is facilities financing
facilities
which are accessible to these
governments to do that
providing some loans at a low rate
through the imf for example so that they
can afford to import and then you know
pay back at their own
pace of course the best way to help make
food imports affordable again is to get
ukraine's exports back to the global
market
international negotiations have been
trying to do just that
but even with a deal in place
longer-term weaknesses in the world's
food system would remain
which is why experts continue to warn
about the prospects for a world that
remains too dependent on too few
countries for its food
less than 10 countries count for around
of our exports for key commodities like
wheat like corn like rice like soybean
so when there is a shock in any one of
these countries whether it be climate
whether it be conflict
you see the consequences of that across
the world
some countries are trying to insulate
themselves from these shocks by becoming
more self-sufficient
it's an attractive idea
and this year the world bank announced
that it's making 30 billion dollars
available to help countries become more
food secure
but it's only part of the answer to
avoiding another crisis
the reality is that
it's just too economically infeasible to
be self-sufficient
most countries will always need to
import some food
and as the climate crisis worsens
global food shocks are set to become
ever more frequent
and harder to predict so it makes sense
not to put all of your eggs in one
basket
if you are a country which relies on
imports make sure
that your import base
is not so
small that it is diversified so if one
country stops somebody else can jump in
where is our insurance for something as
basic as national food security
the world is already starting to
understand the true cost of volatile
prices absolute levels of global hunger
in 2022 could be the highest ever
but without making some fundamental
changes to how the world's food is
supplied
the next crisis could be even more
deadly
what's at stake is the whole global
order
unsufficient nourishment
for millions upon millions of people
this is not only about today this is
also about tomorrow
it is our collective problem
[Music]
thank you very much for watching and if
you want to learn more about the global
food crisis please click on the link and
don't forget to subscribe